Now let me quickly show you the Matrix representation of
the same. These cells are in
Black because they stand for their weight. Excuse
me the bias.
so the threshold for the activation function
of course the order of
Matrix multiplication is not computed commutative.
So the number of rows must
match the number of columns in the excuse me. The number of columns must
match the number of rows.
for the vector or Matrix on the
right, so we multiply this and we will get
a new vector
And what is this Vector? What are the components of the vector? Well, is
this product? It's the sum.
It's the weight more. It's the random
weight multiplied by the bias.
It's the input first input multiplied by
its weight the second to put multiply its weight and we do this for all
three perceptron so really
And that's this what it is. So if we would if
we would take the sum of these products.
this would be the components of the
hidden layer
and then what we do?
Is we pass this vector?
And I'm using Z here because that's the convention for
Activation to this activation function.
And what the activation function will do is it will go through these components
check the signal.
This one is negative 4 so it will be brought down to
zero and then what we're going to do is we're going to again append device
term the bias numerical value.
added to the
to the vector this activation Factor will then be passed on
to the
the upper layer
if you notice
this Vector corresponds to
this
so 32. This is
one that this whole part is the one vector.
We have three components.
And these three components form the vector and this Vector will be passed to
the activation function of the last perceptron.
And that's what we have here.
So we do this.
dot product
and then we will have a single component.
Once again, we'll output this to the activation function.
the return value of this actually the evaluated value
of this activation function is
zero
So imagine we're trying to do we would try to
do binary classification. Is this a property or not?
So let's say because the property was too small.
The signal was too weak. And so we classify it
as a non-property.
And this is true if you want to for example classify something as fraud or
not fraud spam or not spam.
And that's really the idea.